MLB Network Sports Illustrated and of
course spot Fox Sports Tom Verducci how
are you Tom I'm great rich how are you
I'm doing fine
I know you've been around to Yankee
postseason games for quite some time and
I know the new Yankee Stadium gets a lot
of grief and rightfully so about the
pricing and how somebody people don't
sit in those fancy cushy seats from the
television it sounded like the old
Yankee Stadium last couple of nights Tom
what was it like in that in that Stadium
absolutely it did have echoes of the old
park I still think the old park was
completely different that place would
literally shake when the people got loud
I remember Paul O'Neill when he scored a
run of the 96 World Series telling me
that the ground the actual field was
shaking it was so loud I'm not gonna go
there but last night man there was a lot
of energy in the ballpark and I can tell
you that you know this team this Yankee
team fairly young of course not a lot of
[ __ ] experience for a lot of them they
played three winter go home games and
they've all been at home and they won
them all and I can tell you that the
atmosphere there has had something to do
with it I'm not saying they won because
they were all but this team right now in
those three games they were feeding off
the crowd and now they go back to a
place where they've had some some bad
memories from the midge bugs ten years
ago to what we saw on Friday night with
Joe Girardi still mystifies me why he
didn't challenge that why did he not
challenge that because I'm not accepting
the fact that he didn't want to disrupt
his pitchers rhythm when his catchers do
that all the time and the best way to
keep a pitcher in rhythm is to put him
on the on the dugout bench when you're
out of the inning so why do you think he
did not challenge that Tom that's a
great question the only thing I can
think of if you look at the pattern of
the Yankees challenges over the course
of a season they had the highest
percentage of overturns seventy-five
percent so they actually don't challenge
that much they challenge when okay it's
obvious that we're going to get this
call and the first replays showed that
it was I don't know 50/50 maybe could
gone either way now of course you plant
a playoff game as you said the
difference between being off the field
for having the bases loaded the
risk/reward tells you
you must challenge even if you have an
inkling a long shot of winning the
challenge and that's the only thing like
it I can take Tyler I mean cos you're
already credit after he slept on it you
know he got rid of the excuse and said
hey my bad I made a mistake but also
let's put some blame on the coaching
staff too because somebody has to get in
your grill and say no we need to
challenge this thing our catcher is
insinuating he's telling us but the ball
hit the bat we have nothing to lose
let's go ahead and challenge that's on
the whole step yeah because there is
nothing it's not like football where
where you lose a challenge and then that
is significant or timeout even there
there really is no penalty for losing a
challenge in baseball is that yeah and
that's why I didn't buy the excuse that
hey I'm a former catcher I didn't want
to disrupt my pitchers rhythm I mean
first of all I mean who goes out to the
mound more than Gary Sanchez he's
talking about disrupting pitchers rhythm
second of all Jack green wasn't in a
great rhythm at the time he probably
could have used a little bit of hey slow
it down here I think that was just
grasping for an excuse actually and then
the next day like I said he said all
right there's no excuses for that I
messed up move on Tom Verducci MLB
Network joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show so preview it for me how do
you think game 5 plays out in Cleveland
Tom obviously you don't have a crystal
ball and it's been so crazy so far so
it's difficult to predict but what do
you think well Frank all this tips on
Corey Kluber in game 5 you know I think
he disrupted his rotation the first 4
games just to have Bluebird in Game five
because Kluber told him at the end of
the season hey I'd like an extra day
going into the postseason but my second
start I want to stay on that fifth day
his er a is about 1.67 but he stays on
the fifth day he's a creature of habit
like starting pitchers so the fact that
they ran Bauer out there on short rest
and I never bought the fact that hey
this guy's got a rubber arm he's made
for short rest his numbers are terrible
on short rest there's nobody who's made
for short rest that completely opposite
of what they do it was all about
protecting Corey Kluber and having him
fresh and calm
in game 5 that's what he's got he has to
win the game
simple as that this game is on Corey
Kluber Rich I can tell you before this
postseason started if you gave me any
pitcher in this tournament to win one
game my choice would have been it still
is Corey Kluber and I understand the a
key got to him a game too but I think
he's gonna be on point in this game Tom
Verducci MLB Network Sports Illustrated
Fox Sports joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show why the world of Dusty Baker
take out Matt Scherzer
yesterday do you think Tom that's a
great question I'm not sure if dusty
went out there with his mind made up of
what he was going to do which I never
liked if you're a manager and you're
leaving the dugout yeah I'd rather have
you go out there with conviction one way
or the other than to go out there and
see which way the wind is blowing
apparently Matt Wieters had a
conversation that you know giving him a
little bit of doubt on what kind of
stuff Scherzer had there but I'm with
you I mean you have to and I understand
the game now is so much about bullpens
we're seeing that the postseason as well
but sure there's a different cat you
know I've checked all of his numbers
when he pitches third time around he
actually gets better and I think he's
the rare guy that you win or lose with
and I want the game in his hand you know
who knows what does these real reason is
but I think probably the conversation on
the mound convinced him maybe he should
lose in it maybe I need somebody else so
how is arrieta's health going into this
big game for where the Cubs can knock
out the Nationals Tom I think Jake
usually responds well to rest especially
this time of year he did that in Game
seven of the World Series last year
until you get out there and really game
situation it with that hamstring who
knows but I think from what I'm hearing
all all signs are go for him it doesn't
sound like that's going to be an excuse
it'll hold him back he's been shaky this
year I mean I shouldn't say shaky I
should say inconsistent right I mean
there's been some times where the
command is not they're better lately I
think he's got such a good game but I
think it short leash off a couple more
questions with
Verducci here on the Rich Eisen show I
mentioned this last week and I said at
the top of the show somebody's gonna
have to knock the Cubs out some of these
can have to look too many hi and
actually end their reign and I'm
wondering who's gonna do it who do you
think that does have the best chance to
do it diamond Dodgers have the best
chance I mean I like with the GFR on the
ad said after and it's Diamondbacks in
three games I get it but he said that
was the best display of granny out
at-bats that he's ever seen now maybe he
didn't see you know the 98 Yankees are
the Oh four Red Sox but I get the point
at that team right now they've got a
certain vibe going there where the
Dodgers have become a team that grinds
it out I mean wouldn't you ever say that
about the glamour boys from LA right
yeah well I like the vibe that they've
got there listen I thought it's the most
overrated losing streak I've ever seen
in the years covering baseball twas that
streak the Dodgers had there for what
five six weeks and they're losing games
they were 21 games up I mean that's like
having a 30-point leading the fourth
quarter where you just you know empty
the bench and take some guys out they
weren't really playing playoff caliber
baseball at that point this is a very
deep team I love the way Darvish is
throwing the ball now yeah I think they
are the biggest obstacles and Cubs yeah
I always say that they're the pluckiest
quarter billion dollar team you'll ever
see right and then you know what we'll
end up having time to talk about the
Astros who I think are they're terrific
I mean what they do and how they go
about it and Verlander coming up big in
this series just shows you how what a
smart move they made at the deadline
we're not even post deadline actually
rethink and go ahead and get them they
are fontina and Altuve
is just you know I'll tell you because I
told this to Gammons the other day
interviewing Jerry Seinfeld a couple
weeks ago he talked about what he loves
about baseball is the democracy of
talent and physique that you can have an
Erin judge in a Jose Altuve in an MVP
race and there's no other sport like
that you know and I love it I love watch
he's my favorite player to watch play no
matter where he is other bases in the
back in the field
yeah and he always seems to come up the
right spot like he's always lurking in
the on-deck circle and you somebody his
size normally you don't use the word
lurk but he definitely does he's
terrific but like I said what will have
at least next couple 10 days to talk
about them what do you think the
post-mortem for the Red Sox is well
we'll see I mean there's definitely
questions about the manager right John
Farrell was not hired by Dave Dombrowski
that's that's always shaky ground when
things don't go right and I think based
on the trades that were made you know
going back to Kimball and some of those
big deals they made Chris Sale you know
they would always for this year not to
get out in the first round so we'll see
let's not I thought they were
overmatched in this regard rich that the
game right now I sense about bullpens
offensively it's about home runs nobody
is winning games without a home run in
the postseason last year keys were three
and twenty-two without a home run the
way we used to think about postseason
you know small ball move over get them
in forget it about hitting the ball out
of the ballpark and the Red Sox just
couldn't match Houston it turns up
changing games quickly and that is
something they're going to have to
address they have some really good
players and talented players they put
the ball in play but they don't change
the game often enough with power and I
think that's what they're gonna have to
address because that's what's in this
game is as long as they keep using the
ball they have now rich you gonna have
to win with power yeah and even when
they were down by two in the ninth
inning Tom they got a home run but it
didn't leave the yard Tom love chat with
you we'll chat down the road enjoy that
game father I'll be watching that's for
sure of my kids yeah you got outs Tom
Verducci
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about